locals are going to be hitting the links
for a great cause soon as United Way of
Southern Nevada will be hosting its
annual golf tournament that's on
Thursday May 11th Julian high is here to
tell us more about that he is the
president and CEO of United Way of
Southern Nevada Julian thanks for being
here it's so good to see you again
Kendall thank you for having me always
great to have you here let's talk about
the tournament first off it takes place
in Henderson right Revere at the Revere
golf club uh May 11th as you mentioned
and last year we had 300 golfers and
this year we're planning to do it all
over again because if there's such a
great Community response well luckily
you have 38 whole 36 holes to work with
so you you can spread out over time
right exactly that's fantastic and if
people want to sign up still because I
know you have good numbers already but
uh if there's still time where should
people go to sign up I like to send them
to my favorite website in the whole
world
uwsn.org golf and they can sign up and
also contribute to United Way of
Southern Nevada this tournament is
special because it's kicking off the
65th anniversary well this is actually
the bookend for our 65th anniversary so
it's wrapping it up we're in the final
months of our 65th anniversary
celebration we still have you know
several months to go because 65 is a big
year yeah uh but yes this is a the
bookend for that uh for that celebration
65 years of doing wonderful things in
the community for anyone who may not be
familiar with some of the things United
Way does it's an umbrella that covers a
lot of non-profits yes we we work in
three primary areas we work in Student
Success Workforce Development and then
crises and emergency funding which is
you know trying to help organizations
who help who are helping people before
they are really in a crisis or emergency
situation whether it be
um whether it be electric electric bill
assistance or gas bill assistance or
rent you know assistance so those
emergency and crisis funds are really
really important and we're seeing that
there's an increase in need for that
here in southern Nevada yeah do you see
that need still increasingly we got
through the pan endemic but is there
still a residual effect there is there
is a residual effect and in fact this
year alone we run a grant process
ourselves and we saw a considerable
difference between what was requested by
our non-profit partners and what was
what we're actually able to fund so
we'll be coming back to the community at
some point to ask the generous Las Vegas
Community to help us bridge that gap of
course the golf tournament is one way
people can give back but as you
mentioned they can go to the website and
simply give for the sake of giving yes
for the sake of giving and we want to
thank our generous and our sponsor of
stations casinos and also our Golf
co-chair and host Marty Cordoba who's a
uwsn board member for their incredible
generosity helping us make this a
success all right Julian uh thank you
for all you're doing in southern Nevada
I appreciate you being here thank you
for having me very much United Way of
Southern Nevada is always there to help
and if you want more information you can
call that number on your screen
702-892-2300 or as Julian said you can
go to their website
uwsn.org and if you want more on the
golf tournament just go slash golf we'll
be right back